there's the sound of Victory last night
Kansas City erupting after the win in
the Super Bowl by the Chiefs it's Court
night last night in Kansas City now it's
time to look ahead though to the next
Super Bowl right here in Las Vegas thank
you for joining us here on 8 news now
I'm John langler last night's Super Bowl
ended in Arizona with a late
game-winning field goal by Kansas City
and now the Super Bowl and all that
comes with it is headed right here to
Las Vegas this morning what you're
seeing there the NFL unveiled the
official Super Bowl logo for the first
time Ron Futrell is live at Allegiant
stadium with some of the details on this
official handoff that happened today in
Glendale Ron good afternoon
yeah hey there John good afternoon they
have barely cleaned up the confetti off
the slippery Turf in Arizona and we're
already we're already talking about the
next Super Bowl coming up of course
because it's going to be played here at
Allegiant stadium in Las Vegas that's
pretty exciting certainly for that to be
happening they had the official handoff
ceremony today in downtown Phoenix for
the Super Bowl Larry Fitzgerald handing
the ball off literally the former
Cardinals receiver to Steve Hill from
the convention Authority now the team
has been the Vegas team has been in
Arizona most of the week learning from
the team in Phoenix the logo unveiled
today it's got the Las Vegas sign in the
background with the traditional NFL
Roman numerals for the 58th Super Bowl
and while Las Vegas has a relatively
short window to put all this together
only two years events like this one have
been in the works for decades
we have one opportunity to get the first
Super Bowl in Las Vegas right we are
going to work very hard we have an
exceptional team we've been working to
do this for 60 years so we are excited
about the opportunity we excite we're
excited about the team that we have put
together in Las Vegas in order to make
this happen
also CBS
showing the bus the bus leaving Arizona
and heading through the desert to Las
Vegas so if you haven't heard this by
now we're going to tell you we'll tell
you many times between now and February
11 2024 the game will be broadcast on 8
news now so we're certainly happy about
that so mark your calendars only
363 days away from Super Bowl 58 being
held here in Las Vegas John I'm thinking
we should do a graphic lower third below
the screen with a countdown clock on it
is it too early for that do you think we
talked about that this morning so I
think that work is in progress I guess
the question is how long the bus will
take to get from Glendale to Las Vegas
it's not usually a long drive we'll see
if they can put the pedal to the metal
Ron thank you very much of course
there's a lot of money around the big
game as well and it's not just the
betting it's estimated consumers spent
16 and a half billion dollars this year
in Super Bowl related spending the
average American put out 85 bucks Super
Bowl Sunday